at long last filmmaker M night Shyamalan
has completed a trilogy of movies that
he secretly started back in the year
2000 with an breakable
true to form as ever he left plenty of
twists in store for the final act it was
almost too much to keep track of so
let's break down what happened during
the ending of glass
unbreakable introduced viewers to Elijah
price aka mr. glass
a mysterious intense and seemingly
imbalanced comic book dealer after
discovering security guard David Dunn to
be the sole survivor of a devastating
train wreck Pryce spends the movie
encouraging him to embrace the idea that
he's been gifted with superhuman
abilities in the grounded world of the
movie it comes off as a wacky idea but
Elijah is ultimately proven right David
slowly comes to realize he's nearly
invulnerable can see into people's
thoughts by touching them and possesses
incredible strength reluctantly he
begins putting his powers to use in an
effort to bring evildoers to justice a
security guard on a grand scale of
course this being an M night Shyamalan
picture there's more to the story than
initially meets the eye
Elijah's motives for awakening David to
his powers are far from altruistic it's
revealed that he actually orchestrated
the deadly events that led to his
discovery of David in the first place
causing many other incidents of domestic
terror before sabotaging the east rail
177 train Elijah sees himself as a
perfect foil to done superhero there's
plenty of symmetry backing up Elijah's
point of view right down to the rare
bone disease that renders him just as
physically fragile as David is strong
but David refuses to play by the rules
of its would-be arch-nemesis
Azzam breakable ends we learn that
Elijah has been arrested and committed
to an institution for the criminally
insane and that was the end of the story
until split David refuses to be drawn
into a super rivalry with Elijah but
that doesn't mean he rejects to pretend
to love his powers outright as we learn
about in class David a dobbsy alter ego
of the overseer dedicating himself to
ferreting out evil of the assistance of
his son Joseph it would have been
interesting to learn more about David's
exploits and the time between and
breakable and splits since fans of the
first movie has spent years wondering if
a more traditional sequel could be on
the way instead audiences are
reintroduced to David at a pivotal
moment
she learns about the existence of Kevin
Wendell crumb aka the Horde who's
psychotic exploits become public during
splits closing minutes when class begins
we see David trying to track down Kevin
in an effort to foil his latest
kidnapping and he does a pretty good job
after bumping into Kevin on the streets
and learning his dark secrets he heads
straight for Kevin's hideout frees his
victims and then faces off against his
adversary their showdown is cut short by
the arrival of well-prepared law
enforcement who show up determined to
take both men into custody
not just Kevin without so much as a
court hearing that dueling superhumans
are locked up inside a mental
institution one that has also spent
years housing a lighter price with David
and Kevin at the institution Elisha has
all the pieces in place to execute a
masterwork of super villainy with the
overseer Elisha has his perfect
adversary in the hoard he has a useful
Ally several of them are chilly Kevin
lives with 24 distinct personalities
including the supernatural one called
the Beast this personality is imbued
with incredible strength the ability to
climb walls and a desire to rid the
world of impure individuals who have
never known suffering Elijah is
physically weak but intellectually
brilliant or kevin is incredibly strong
but psychologically unstable together
they team up to execute an escape plan
teasing the audience with a climactic
showdown in the heart of Philadelphia
but what Elijah says he wants to do is
not what he's actually going to do as
they make their way out of the
psychiatric facility only mr. glass
knows the full shape of what's really
going on it sounds like the bad guys
teaming up
Elijah's plan is to expose the existence
of superheroes to the world on a grand
scale letting people know beyond the
shadow of a doubt that humans are
capable of extraordinary things just
like in the comic books he loves so much
at first he claims his plan is to have
the Horde and the overseer go toe-to-toe
with each other at the high-profile
opening of a new skyscraper in downtown
Philadelphia but once he escapes the
facility with Kevin they never get
further than the parking lots neither
David Kevin nor Elijah make any effort
to get to the tower for their showdown
instead having their fight on the
hospital grounds to the audience it
seems like Elijah's plan is going off
the rails and that is going to be
prevented from completing its mission of
waking people up to the existence of
superheroes by the end of the movie
we learn that everything
actually going according to plan in the
hospital parking lots the overseer and
the [ __ ] Duke it out with each other or
mr. glass watches and provides
commentary almost like the whole battle
is a movie hysterectomy or the wild dr.
le staple is frantically attempting to
bring reinforcements of some kind to the
facility in order to bring the situation
under control when they arrive one of
the most shocking moments in the movie
happens we're not talking about the
reveal that Elijah's derailment of East
rail 177 also killed Kevin's dad for
that twist implying that mr. glass
essentially created the Horde is
relatively tame compared to what happens
next when staples armed reinforcements
show up there once again suspiciously
prepared for the spectacle at hand
instead of trying to de-escalate the
situation peacefully they instead start
trying to kill the superhumans
exploiting their weaknesses to catch
them off guard dr. Stapleton lists case
he to law the horde away from the beasts
persona and back to his baseline
identity of Kevin Wendell Crum once he's
got the body of a normal human being
again he's fatally shot by staples back
up he's not the only one to get such
merciless treatment after fighting with
Kevin in a tank of water
David strength is severely compromised
he's thrown off by being submerged and
the source of his one weakness and when
dr. staples backup approaches him just
like SWAT team members he's powerless to
fight back instead of helping him or
trying to take him peacefully the men
take ahold of David and drown him to
death in a puddle of water it's a
devastating moment for viewers who went
in expecting a more traditional ending
to the story as we all should have
probably expected Shyamalan has no
interest in giving people what they
expect No before David dies at the hands
of her backer but dr. staple decides to
explain to him just what's really been
going on at the facility essentially
she's been gaslighting all three of them
attempting to make them believe that
their superpowers are only a delusion
she wasn't trying to help any of the
superhumans she was trying to stop them
you're not going to shake my hair after
taking dr. staples hand David sees in
his final vision as she is a part of an
elaborate secret society one that has
spent a very long time trying to prevent
real superheroes from gaining a foothold
in the wider consciousness dr. staples
job is to go from city to city hunting
down isolated incidents of superheroism
and shutting them down before they get
too much attention
she says she prefers to do this in a
non-lethal way convincing people to give
up their so-called delusions - that she
can spare their lives if they don't well
she lets her teammates kill them
she also lets Elijah die from injuries
he suffered when the Beast turned his
awesome strength on him after it was
revealed that he was responsible for the
death of Kevin's father once the three
superhumans are dead the members of the
mysterious society who all share the
same tattoo of a clover on the wrist set
about erasing all the evidence that
indicates a fight between superhumans
even happened dr. staple previously told
Elijah that more than a hundred cameras
were recording activity on the
facility's crowns and her group goes
about the process of erasing order
footage they advise regular staff
members of the hospital to keep the
incident to themselves and to almost
look like they're going to successfully
sweep everything under the rug like
they've apparently done so many times
before but again that's not what
actually happens turns out nothing that
dr. staple can do is capable of stopping
mr. glasses true plan um but no is to
dr. staple the overseer or the Horde mr.
glass made arrangements to record all of
the surveillance cameras at some
off-site location broadcasting the
footage elsewhere so that it couldn't be
erased this cache of valuable video is
then sent to Joseph Casey and mrs. price
all of whom were there to see the
fantastic events as they unfold air
thanks to Elijah's data drop with the
three survivors of more than just their
eyewitness testimony they have footage
of superhuman feats recorded by dozens
of cameras which they can now blast out
into the world defeating the scheme of
dr. staples secret society after the
superhumans are dead these three regular
strangers work together to share the
footage with the world uploading it to
the Internet and then they sit and wait
as people around them begin to hear the
incredible news all around them a people
see if their own eyes what seems to be
proof of the existence of superheroes
the secret societies mission has been
foiled mister glasses plan was a success
the biggest twisting glass aside from
the reveals of the hoards wheel origin
story mr.
versus real plan and the unexpected
deaths of the main characters is
arguably the existence of the secret
society it's clear from the glimpses we
get that the group possesses significant
resources to help them execute their
mission but the film gives us very
little insight into what the
organization actually is or what it
might do now that the cats out of the
bag regarding the whole superhero thing
they apparently want to maintain balance
in the world but now that balance is
tipping not only does the archive of
security camera footage show real
superheroes in action
it also shows proof of dr. staples
organization and blatantly executing
David and Kevin both of whom are
basically defenseless at the time
they're killed David's death is
particularly merciless and now it's on
tape for the world to see more there be
repercussions as their mission
effectively over the ending doesn't tell
us but from dr. staples blood-curdling
scream after she realizes what's
happened the outlook for her group it
doesn't look too good
as the footage makes its way into the
world mrs. price once again channels her
son's obsession with comics declaring it
to be the beginning of a universe she
believes wholeheartedly that Elijah was
right and that the reveal of real
superheroes will only inspire more
extraordinary people to step out of the
shadows recognize their powers and
change the world it's the sort of setup
that cries out for a sequel so of course
Shyamalan has said he's not doing one
speaking in an interview with vulture in
the days leading up to glasses released
the filmmakers shut down all speculation
about a sequel movie saying simply yeah
we're not doing that though I have the
sequel rights to most of my movies
essentially for the reason to not do
them if he's telling the truth about
that then it seems like glasses hopeful
ending it's meant to be a tease for your
imagination only rather than a promise
about what's to come in keeping with the
trilogy second installment people up in
very split on their reactions to the
final movie whether you love it or hate
it you almost have to admire glass for
doing pretty much exactly the opposite
of what audience is expected and still
somehow leaving you wanting more check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more loop of videos about your
favorite movies a coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
to you don't miss a single one
[Music]